it depends on what game you're in before
you get enough traction uh and start
learning the things and ins and out you
have to prove yourself from the very
beginning sure in my case I had a good
reference which was the gentleman that I
had been spoken about earlier and I was
able to get acquainted with the gang
without having to do a serious
um yeah serious crime or initiation from
the get-go yeah and so you know I'm in
I'm learning and I get my street name I
get you know I get my responsibilities
my roles and as I start studying into
the inner workings of the gang I find
that there's a huge religious connection
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to LD live today we have on
the show Johnny with us he is a former
gang member who was one month away from
taking his oath which would mean that he
could not leave and if he did he would
get killed fortunately Jesus got a hold
of him and he's with us today to tell
his story welcome Johnny thank you thank
you so much for for having me it's such
a privilege to be able to tell what God
has done in my life and you know
everyone has a different story right and
um it that's the one of the coolest
things about being a Christian is that
each person we get to meet they have a
different past it allows them to connect
with different people and it just shows
the glory of God so looking forward to
sharing how the Lord has led in my life
it also shows how personal God is you
know the way he reached you is totally
different than how he reached me or
these two you know it's like every
person
he has a he knows exactly what's going
to open your eyes to him you know I love
that that's right I'm glad you're here
as a witness instead of being like under
the witness protection program
you probably had a gang name and all
that kind of stuff too right yeah yep
yep all in the past so you're going to
tell us a little bit about kind of how
all this started and that means you're
probably going to go back
a little bit further yeah yeah you saw
all stories start from the beginning
right that's right so so how did it
start for you yeah that's a good
question you know I'm um early age as
most of you could tell right
um so I grew up in a in in a generation
that had access to technology you know
um I probably received my first
um access independent access to
technology probably around the age of
seven wow with the flip phone whoa
that's young very young very young and
you know I grew up in a household to
where my mom and dad were like really
good friends but they weren't marriage
uh they weren't compatible for marriage
they basically divorced when I was
around two and um my father had some
interesting choices in life he was I had
a drinking habit and so
um that kind of led a lot to their
divorce and the reasoning behind it and
uh and he he in and out of my adolescent
life was thrown into prison for you know
various things and so
it's kind of an interesting environment
to get to you know with the get-go you
know and uh so but my mom was the type
of person and because my dad loved me so
much and they were friends she was like
I still want him to be involved in your
life and so in and out of prison my
father was always around ironically he
would live five houses up or down the
street and or around the corner or in
the next town by he was always around
when he was out of prison so it's a very
interesting situation
um but with my dad out of the picture
that'll use my mom being a single mom
right and single moms have tons of
challenges and I think they have more
challenges today than they have ever
faced in the past because of all the
technological advancements I mean it's
just
it's crazy and
um growing up having this kind of
environment
um my father struggled with alcohol as
his addiction and but my mom and her
struggles was food and so growing up I
had kind of a pool of influence of
substance abuse and a pool of influence
from uh addiction to food and so you
know you can imagine I grew up eating
anytime I wanted snacking in between
meals and I met him at Wildwood which is
it's called Wildwood Health Institute
you are taking the
the Wildwood Health event evangelism
training so you were like full-on vegan
and healthy and I'm like you what no way
it was so that was so funny yeah I'll
share it as we go a little bit further
how how this influenced my life and how
big I got but you know just thinking
from a from a little age a lot of
parents don't know the influences that
their parents have on their children and
and really a lot of their influences
determine their uh kids actions as they
grow up yeah early childhood development
so important and you can form so many
habits early on that it can affect you
the rest of your life yep yeah and in
this case you know as I said my my diet
was bad as a child you know soda and you
know just everything that typical kid
would eat and um we didn't really have a
strong religious structure in the home I
could probably count on the amount of my
feet on my fingers amount of times I
went to church and uh so there was no
strong religious upbringing no emphasis
is really on Christ it was just mainly
my mom trying to survive dealing with
the stress and my dad being in out of
prison and um you know with all of this
in my home I began seeking attention in
school and so naturally I was the
Troublemaker in class starting fights
getting kicked out of school suspended
and so on and that started adding to my
mom's stress bank so you know what I
mean and um I was as I look back at my
issues in school one of it was seeking
attention yeah but another one is I got
independent access to the internet at a
very young age so I mentioned around six
or seven I got a flip phone but by the
time I was nine or ten I had my own iPod
Touch wow and you know at that age it's
not just games that you're playing it's
things that you know so let me let me
ask you a question and clana clarify for
our audience would it be safe to assume
that prayer wasn't a big part of your
life either yeah there was no prayer no
Bible study no church yeah so you're not
even like praying for meals like you
would find in a typical Christian home
yeah okay and then
um second thing would be like
why why do you think you had those
devices was it like uh
we're trying to keep Johnny happy is it
like parents trying to buy affection or
just trying to keep you busy or occupied
or why the devices at the young age do
you think that's a good question
if I were to step into my parents minds
I think it was just because they thought
it was something that was good to do you
know I didn't see it was a harmful thing
it's like oh he likes it it's fun it
makes him happy yeah I mean with no
strong religious morality so it's a toy
it was a toy yeah growing up I had a uh
my parents well my dad mostly he was
pretty materialistic and he would
frequently swap out the TVs and he just
gave them to my brother and I and we had
our own computers and man I I devoured
Nickelodeon MTV and I cannot explain to
you how much junk I saw growing up and
in secret because my parents wouldn't
know right like so like he said it's
it influences you it really does and a
gaming addiction that started with a
flip phone yeah that's right yeah
I wasn't a flip phone for me it was but
we my brother and I had our own
computers and now I was the total tomboy
which is the gaming all the time a
little Breakout game or whatever yeah I
don't know which one it was but I was
like Halo Call of Duty Grand Theft Auto
like all the time so it's one thing I
always try to explain to my kids is like
yes you know there's all these devices
around and you know my I may have this
or I may have that but whatever we buy
is it a tool or is it a toy yeah yeah
you know if it's a toy then you have to
sit there and think about well do I yeah
do I really need this you know is it is
it really gonna help me if it's a tool
yeah it's okay you know as long as
you're using it for the right right
purposes but yeah and you know just like
with anything with any addiction can
start with one small step right you know
as I look and reflect on my experience
it was first it was the uh Playstation
One
you know the flip phone then PlayStation
2 iPod touch and then you know as time
progressed it was PlayStation 3 Xbox 360
and all the you know no religious
background all the games that come with
it are rated you know in for mature
right you know whatever and so you know
uh it all started one small step and
this opened me to
lack a better terms a portal of
information and things that I never knew
existed and I'm already in school I'm
causing trouble I'm hanging out the
wrong crowd getting in the fights and
all these things and now I have this
independent access to video games and
internet my mind starts being filled
with the wrong type of media do you
think that playing aggressive games sets
you up towards becoming a gang member
later on absolutely and it's not only
the video games
um it had a large play Grand Theft Auto
and these kinds huge effect on my mind
but the music I was listening to
gangster rap hip-hop all of that stuff
was I really enjoyed that and the movies
I like to watch I had kind of this
obsession with movies about gangs I used
to watch uh documentaries about gangs
all this independent access on the
internet about gangs it at from a young
age playing these games and listening
this music and all these things watching
these things it I really wanted to be
come that it was my dream when people
ask you know hey what do you want to be
when you grow up in my heart I wanted to
be a gangster wow it makes me think of
the tree of knowledge you know people
think why would God want to keep anyone
from knowledge but it's the knowledge of
Good and Evil so when you have access to
this and you see all this evil it's that
by beholding you become changed good uh
Bad Company corrupts good morals and all
those things you're you're putting these
bad things before your eyes and we're
naturally sinful Fallen creatures and we
get drawn to those things seduced by
those things so yeah the the internet is
almost like this tree of forbidden
knowledge you know
was it just
I mean was it I mean I I think of gangs
as kind of can be a broad thing
um I'm essentially like mafias like a
gang you know it's maybe
you know more Italian or people might
consider it to be more I don't know high
class or whatever but
um were you into that kind of stuff too
or is it more like Street
gang and that's it yeah I was more into
street gangs
um and you know just the obsession with
um drugs and power and the kind of the
notoriety you know the influence that
people would have and you know as I look
back and you know I see the media that
I'm looking at and all the influences
have on my mind and then in school
hanging out with the wrong crowd you
know as my middle school years are going
and Ticking getting in more and more
trouble getting expelled and all these
things
um
and my father at some point got out of
prison
and he found a new addiction
and it was not alcohol it was of
substances you know he got into drugs
yeah and
um that kind of changed my
my living scenario quite a bit up to now
my mom was more into food and that
addiction that's how she dealt with
stress all this stuff in school she's
causing her to eat some more and delve
into that side my father in and out for
you know alcohol addiction but now he's
good now and now not just him but my
family's in the drugs
and pull it back together so he he lived
down the road
um well actually that's a good question
when he gets out of prison most times we
would house him until he got onto his
own feet and so I believe looking back
it was at that intermedium stage where
he's still with us until he gets on his
own feet and um this is where drugs he
introduced into the family and when you
look at it from my mom's standpoint
right she is so stressed her son is you
know running havoc in school she's one
you know single parent predominantly his
father just got out of prison there's a
lot of things going on what can I do to
lessen my stress I'm not gonna drink
because my ex-husband does that night
don't like that what can I have you know
and so my family digs into that and
after a while as you can imagine with
the people I'm hanging out with and all
the media I've been consuming
the natural thing is for me to get into
drugs myself yeah what age I started uh
consuming at first at the age of 13. no
and so
independent access around nine or ten of
the you know of internet and then just a
few years later
this Step at 13 deciding to do that did
you try to start proving yourself kind
of early on in your friend group like
doing extreme things or
you know trying to prove how tough you
are or something like that kind of of
your own volition because you were into
that lifestyle and wanted to be that
person that's a good question
um I was always
kind of a natural
it was more natural for me to do trouble
making and then and in my circles I was
more of a of a leader
um and except for in the case that uh I
was in the older crowds and I did look
up to them and their behavior you know
their influence had quite a bit on me
but for the most part I was really my
mind says being independent about what I
wanted
um so it was it was interesting but that
was in the school environment
you know
um fast forwarding just a little bit you
know my drug addiction continues like
I'm about 15 now and things are getting
so bad in my household in the beginning
was a secret right but you can't hold
that secret too too long so now my whole
family is supportive of my addiction my
father goes back to prison and it
becomes not just a little thing here and
there my whole my mom and me are just in
we're stuck like you guys were taking
drugs together that's right at 15. yeah
between 14 and 15 and so you can imagine
how deep the hole gets and I dropped out
of high school and I said hey I'm just
gonna do my own thing and that's when I
started running into people that I
started wanting to prove myself to okay
and uh so you know when you get into the
realm of drugs I'm sure most of you know
here you know it's uh you meet people
that you never never otherwise would
have met and I I got linked up with a
gentleman that was almost the age of my
father and we started doing hard
substances Together Like Cocaine yeah
meth and so on you know and uh you know
when you start small it just grows and
grows and grows and you know and if
you're about that if that's what you
want you're gonna find it yeah and um so
you know I got linked up with this guy
and I found out that he was in a in a
gang and this gang is not just a you
know a little high school Clique or you
know something that only exists in one
little small town this was a nationwide
gang and that attracted me more than
anything in the past because this is hey
this is my dream this is what I really
wanted to be in life and the
opportunities here and I started
stepping out to prove myself okay I hear
a lot of you know secret societies gangs
all that stuff the appeal to it is the
family the Brotherhood I got your back
it would would you associate your broken
home to another draw to that besides
just the it looks tough or whatever
because I hear a lot
you know divorce is crazy broken homes
all that is that going to be something
that causes more people to go towards
gangs and things like that that's a good
question I think in many cases it does
because a lot of people are in gangs get
into it because their family is so
broken that they need to help them
whether it means selling drugs to bring
in money or whether you know there's
just a lot of reasons in my case even
though we had some rocks in my boat or
in the family boat my parents were still
very loving caring supportive
hard-working and so you know I I would
say in general I didn't grow up in a
home like most others that would join a
gang yeah and um but there was one thing
about this game
that many people don't know and other
games that that people don't know that
actually drew me in to want to go all
the way okay and that was religion
religion they were Christian
so in the beginning when I started
rubbing shoulders with them
um
I came in in an interesting time and or
excuse me in an interesting way because
depending on what game you're in before
you get enough traction uh and start
learning the things and in ins and out
you have to prove yourself from the very
beginning sure in my case I had a good
reference which was the gentleman that I
had been spoken about earlier and I was
able to get acquainted with the gang
without having to do a serious
um yeah serious crime or initiation from
the get-go yeah and so you know I'm in
I'm learning and I get my street name I
get you know I get my responsibilities
my roles and as I start studying into
the inner workings of the gang I find
that there's a huge religious connection
and this gang was following a religion
called King ism kingism
the whole concept that Jesus Christ was
born as a king and therefore only Latin
Kings can go to heaven Latin likes what
really yeah but Jesus was he was Middle
Eastern yeah yeah and there's a lot to
it that you know we can't dig in that we
won't dig into here because just a lot
of details but Jesus was born a king and
the followers of him are Kings and being
a king is your ticket to heaven and uh
each each King you meet will have a
little bit of a different take on that
um there's a lot of different
information but that's what I was told
was this your first introduction to
Christianity this was it wasn't my first
like I said in the beginning I probably
went to church amount you know the
amount of times I count on my hands so I
had some concept that God was real but I
didn't know anything about God I did
know that Jesus I knew God was real and
that Jesus died for my sins and so when
I got into this that was the real like
wow this is interesting so this is yeah
this is fascinating so I just looked
this out so for you guys and the people
watching this is a fascinating uh kind
of
um recap if you will this is from Oxford
reference this kingism is a spiritual
practice of the street organization the
Almighty Latin king and queen Nation
so they abbreviate that alkqn it refers
to a moral and political way of life
that argues that America is a deeply
racist society and that the so-called
Latino leaders have been planted by the
dominant Society to cause subterfuge
in response a-okqn have emerged as the
true ambassadors and socio-cultural
resistance to the subjugation of
colonial social control
kingism provides members of alq or alkqn
with an alternative Consciousness they
have that in parentheses a positive
forward way of looking at life
in the face of and then it continues and
I guess it's caught up cut off I'd have
to sign up for this thing wow I've never
heard a deal but that's yeah basically
yeah and you know each just each person
is different they have different reasons
why they're in gangs or even in this
particular gang but as I started
studying as I started getting involved
that was for me the biggest thing and so
we had our own prayers we had our own
church meetings they read the from the
Bible yeah they had something that they
would refer to as their Bible so to
speak it was their way their code of
living and they would call God Yahweh
and we had prayers for our brothers and
Fallen sisters and it's very interesting
like prayers prayers for the dead
prayers for the dead prayer for the
living so it's a very very interesting
um experience and I started seeing
myself you know I started getting
interested in God you know I knew God
existed never thought about serving him
but man if Jesus is a gangster I'm all
in so where are you from I'm from Texas
and um this gang is Nationwide right
um the strongest population would
probably be Chicago New York here that's
what he was saying here and they have
chapters all throughout the U.S and and
so on and now they don't only receive
Latinos you might ask well how are you
in if you're a white guy but they have
they don't they're not so strong about
that anymore but you are not a Latino so
you could not be saved no no the that
what uh I could join as a white person
um but the the whole concept is that if
you're a follower of this religion
you'll you'll be saved you have to buy
in yeah it makes you think of Mormonism
kind of like if you want to make it to
Heaven you got to become a Mormon you
got to marry a Mormon or something like
yes and so you know
um this started doing things in my mind
to where
I started seeing myself
on a mission for God to take out all my
other rival gang members in his name as
you know for me
Rivals wasn't about just colors wasn't
just about territory it was about
religion and depending on how deep you
get your allies and you a lot of them
believe that they're worshiping God we
believe we're worshiping God in our
Rivals we saw them as Satan worshipers
wow and so it gets deep when they're
saying that there's done there's a lot
of Destruction or killing done in the
name of God even in the in the Gangland
that's like a gang Crusade yeah that's
what I was saying that a current day
Crusaders yeah and you know I will
repeat this again because it's important
for our viewers to know not every person
that's in is in for this a lot of a lot
of Kings could care less about any of
the religion they're just in for the
whatever reason this shows where your
heart was you were seeking for God
that's right and and you just got
deceived by this thing but you still had
a desire to know him that's right and
that's what makes it so important you
know childhood influences I started off
kind of with the bad right but the fact
that my mom and dad took me to church
maybe 5 five times grown up that gave me
enough seed at this time to be
interested in serving him so you know
some parents may be watching this and be
like man I have made so many mistakes I
mean my kids are just way off the path
but I'm telling you God can use the
little seeds that you sow as a parent
and if and if you didn't have any
religious you know influence on your
children at all God can still use you
today you know and uh so this is this is
was my draw I started getting in and you
know I was doing I was still selling
drugs and so on but
a thought came to me one day
because before I got into all this my
father got sent back to prison
and he started writing me letters about
Jesus
apparently he had found Christ when he
was in prison this time wow but I never
wrote him back I never paid attention
but it was in this moment I felt an
impression hey why don't you reach out
to your dad and let him know how much of
a follower of God you are right and so I
started writing letters to my dad and as
a gang member and the special Latin
Kings they hold to a code of secrecy so
very very if you open up it's uh you
know there's serious consequences for
that and when you're writing between an
inmate you can't mention anything that
has to do with gang Pavilion and that
will just because they'll cut your
letters off so I had to write it to him
in code and so on and so on but he found
out what gang I was in because he was
locked up with some of the uh you know
people in this gang and he started
teaching me about deception some people
may say well man why does Little Live
Studios Focus so much on all the bad
things we get that a lot but let me tell
you something my dad started with this
deception because he knew that's where I
was at he knew I was being deceived and
if it were me I would have probably
started somewhere else but my dad had
wisdom from God to teach me about
deception so he started teaching me
things about Freemasonry secret
societies and then all of the things he
started teaching me little by little my
eyes started being open about the gang
wow I have Freemasons in the gang oh wow
they do this and they do that and this
even though we seem like we're moral all
this other stuff is immoral and you know
step by step God started using my dad's
letters teaching me basic things about
truth to open my eyes wow and he gave me
a Bible tract
some of some people may be against
giving out Bible tracks but let me tell
you my dad gave me a Bible track that he
sent in the letter almost two years
before
I opened it how to give your life to
Jesus was the track he sent it to you
two years prior before you opened it
that's right so you did get it but it
was just
sitting just like all the other letters
I didn't read them didn't touch them
didn't write them back
in there he said do you still have it I
said I think so I looked there was I
confessed my sins gave my life to Jesus
because I was generally interested in
God sure and I said and through a course
of time I said Jesus if you if this is
your way I'm gonna stay in I'm gonna
ride all the way
but if it's not get me out before it's
too late so where does this part come in
where you're going to take an oath
so my dad is teaching me back and forth
I start praying this prayer I give my
life to Christ and I said Lord if this
is your way I'm going to stay in if not
get me out before it's too late
I'm in after about a week or two of
praying that prayer I'm in my backyard
and the biggest question for me to God
am I being deceived is this the truth
I'm in my backyard and I had this very
strong impression the nation is
deceiving you Almighty Latin King we are
all my Lion King Nation not king and
queen Nation uh because of the chapter
but the nation is deceiving me
I called up my friend and you know I had
to make the choice
do I leave the gang and suffer
consequences
or do I just be a follower of man and
fear man rather than God I had a clear
calling from God I had the proof I had
that my eyes were being opened step by
step and here I had the strong
impression
I remember that I hadn't received my
oath but I still didn't know what kind
of consequences I'd get so I was afraid
that they would hurt me my mom
but I decided to follow the voice and
the conviction of the holy spirit I made
a phone call and gave him some reasons
why I wanted to leave in the beginning
the reasons weren't very strong
so they come back to my house about two
weeks later knock on my front door hey
why do you want to leave
and you know our first was given some
lame excuse but then I just finally told
him I said you know what I've been
studying and God has told me that you
are deceiving me and that this is not
the truth and I said I don't want to be
a part of it it's not truth
and uh this individual in fact it was
the individual that had groomed me into
the game he was so deceived that he told
me that that was from Satan
you know imagine really deceived you
know and um by the power of God I was
able to escape and he he told me right
then and there he said you were one
month away from receiving your oath you
were going to be in for life this is
what you were going to receive all this
power all this and this you were one
month away and you want to leave because
of this
yeah imagine if I didn't listen to the
voice of God yeah I'm sure that was a
convincing argument he had he's like
you're so close and the devil's trying
to keep you from getting into the
kingdom you know
yeah you can gain the whole world but
lose your soul that's right
the devil always dangles the carrot
first yeah that's right and so you know
for the viewers that are watching
if the Lord is convicting you about
something you gotta hop on it yeah do
all that you can to follow it because
you don't know you don't know I who
knows how harder it would have been if I
was closer oh yeah you know and being
having this tendency to prove myself to
that crowd particularly you know I don't
know what would happen so you know fast
forward
I come out I wipe my hands clean and now
is a New Journey with Christ
I put away all the drugs except for
marijuana because I'm like well hey God
created it right and so you know my
addiction of marijuana was still running
rampant uh but my dad started teaching
me
and uh you know the Lord he uses
anything you know he started teaching me
through these letters and my dad gave me
this little pocketbook it had like 30
verses in it and called verses of
assurance comfort and salvation and I
would study that every night and
memorize every verse and that was kind
of my Bible right I didn't have anything
else that's how I started and then my
dad started um I got linked up and got a
Bible
and when I got the Bible and started
studying I was convicted about marijuana
three or so years of addiction I
remember looking at my bong one night
and I'm like man that bong water is so
disgusting what what is that I've never
taken drugs it's a pipe and it's sucking
through the water so the water is like a
filter and the water just gets Brown and
nasty and gross yeah and so I'm like
looking at the bong water and the
residue and I'm like man this is so
nasty is is this something that God
would really approve of
and I was convicted throw it away in the
trash
that night God gave me the power to
throw it away in the trash never to
touch drugs since in eight years praise
the Lord and so you know God gave the
power and you know I started reading the
Bible and I get linked up with this
Bible study set that my dad recommended
me called amazing facts uh have you guys
done amazing facts
powerful powerful Bible studies I mean
straight to the point and a quick answer
in question format amazing and this
Bible study set start opening my eyes to
choose to have never heard of before I
mean it just let me on fire that's
awesome
Dougie B yeah
if there's any viewer that's watching
that haven't done amazing facts check
them out I mean they changed my life I
was reading them two or I would do about
two a night and I was just there was
about 27 depending on how deep you want
to get I started doing all these studies
and I read this book and um this book
taught about a particular profit see in
the Bible
found in the Book of Revelation and uh
it started talking about some things
that I'd never heard about before and my
dad sent it to me and I got so peaked
and started studying into these these
prophecies I was like man I had to find
a church that's teaching and believing
these things and so I found a church
nearby about 30 minutes from my house
and I told my mom I said Mom we're gonna
go to church and you can imagine my mom
just watched me wow give up all the
drugs
which um in fact I remember one time the
last time we did drugs together
I had a very that a bad trip and it's
because I did it after I was a Christian
this wasn't marijuana but it was it was
a hard drug it had a bad trip it was a
it was a spiritual bad trip and very
demonic and I told my mom that this is
from the devil and from that day she had
let go of the drugs as well wow and so
God you know she wasn't even a Christian
but he used that so I said let's go to
church and my mom starts driving me to
church right
we started going to church and
at this time I'm studying studying
studying I get baptized about you know
eight months after I started going to
the church and my mom starts seeing
something happen in my life
after I was baptized
you know all these things have changed
stop hanging out with my friends I'm
studying the Bible all the time she
catches me praying early in the morning
and late at night and she just started
noticing all these changes but there's
one thing that convinced her more than
anything else and it's going to be
something that you wouldn't expect
I started losing weight
wow after I was baptized I found a
powerful message from God in the Bible
about health that's amazing I mean is it
Daniel yeah I was in Leviticus first and
learned about cleaning unclean Meats I'm
like man this is powerful I'm like God's
got a health plan so I started falling
clean means I said God this is I'm not
content being here I was 230 pounds by
the way all that food addiction had
grown up and I was 230 pounds and I said
and I used to take comfort Lord
I I called myself fat I said I'm fat but
you love me and I said yeah I love you
son and I took comfort in that but after
a while he told it's like I got the
impression one day I love you so much I
don't want to keep you where you're at
yeah exactly and that convicted me to
study and so I read Leviticus changed my
diet
after about a month or two I'm like Lord
this is not enough I want something
better I go to the Book of Daniel and
read how his diet eating that
plant-based diet changed his mind and
impacted his relationship with God and
being able to receive wisdom and all
these things I'm like Lord if
if my diet impacts my ability to
comprehend your word and to understand
your voice in prayer I want to go to the
next level man so how old are you at
this point I'm about 15 16. so a lot
happened in those you know 13 started
drugs found you know was in the gang fit
at the age of 15 and left at the age of
15. I was in about half a year and then
you know I'm getting baptized and so it
you know a lot of things happening at
once did you go back to school
that's a good question so
after after this conviction about health
I'm vegetarian for about three months
and then I study the Book of Genesis and
I'm like hey I want to follow the
original diet that God has and I started
following a fully plant-based diet and
lose about 90 pounds okay wow so lose
about 90 pounds and that's what convicts
my mom that there's power in the in the
message of this church wow she starts
coming to the church as a member as a
you know as an uh visitor starts doing
Bible studies she's baptized
now that we're baptized family
the call goes the the idea comes to mind
why don't you go to school
and after
we were after I was baptized I would
like to share with you that God put it
upon my heart immediately to start doing
gas evangelism in um in my former gang
territory and my formal rival gang
territory so I would go every night and
pass out some of these books that I read
and bible studies that I read and um
I'll have to tell you a story but it's
it's interesting I remember one night
okay so very quickly I was BC life I'm
guarding the house of of a gang member
and a rival gang member drives up we
have a confrontation he starts circling
around the block
you know what happens when people are
circling around the block they're
preparing for a drive-by shooting check
my waistband no no pistol nothing to
defend myself but a knife call my
buddies no one's there to back me up
they're only one block down the road and
this guy's circling around once
twice and there's a pause
picks up someone else for the second
time uh picks up someone else on that
second lap and then
nothing happens
fast forward I'm doing guest I'm doing
evangelism in the gas station we him and
I meet face to face in his territory wow
he says you remember that day you're
acting funny
I said yeah he said I was fully
convinced to take your life that day but
when I picked up my friend on that
second round he convinced me not to well
that's the reason why you're here today
wow shared the gospel with him and he
wanted to give his life to Christ what
and he did and you know I never followed
up with him from there don't I don't
know his case but you know God can use
us yeah and um so I all this has
happened my mom gets baptized right now
it's time to go back to school
I go back to school and I'm like 14
almost 15 credits behind and I'm
supposed to start as a senior so I'm
basically a year and a half or more
behind but my main objective was Lord
you have him doing Ministry out here at
the gas station the my previous gang
members instead of hating me started
respecting me wow the former gang of
Rivals that I had started respecting me
started appreciating what I was doing
for Christ and now I'm going I said Lord
I want to go on a mission to where
people saw me at my worst high school
and I want to give Bible studies
and uh the Lord opened the door we're in
high school I have about four or five
Bible study students and one of them
went all the way through was baptizing
is my wife today so praise God he went
back to high school and found your wife
that's right that's amazing that's right
and so that you finished up yeah so by
God's grace he allowed me to graduate
that year and uh right then I got right
at the day after graduation got plugged
into full-time Ministry so you were out
of school for a couple years that's
right I went back as a senior and
graduated on time like that's right I
mean that Health message worked right
this is that Daniel was ten times wiser
that's right God was merciful So
eventually you came to Wildwood you took
the health evangelism course and then
the ministry management course graduated
from that with your wife so she took
lifestyle coaching right yes which is
all
you know Health evangelism is basically
teaching people about health showing
that you care just like Jesus show
people that he cared by healing them and
then like having it as an opening wedge
to talk about Jesus
um so you guys both graduated from
Wildwood Center for Health evangelism
and now where are you working now
so yeah Wildwood is a powerful
experience for us and um you know right
after we graduated we got plugged in
with the ministry called streams of
light International and streams like
International basically they're
passionate about evangelism passionate
about getting church members involved
and sharing literature just like I was
when I was at those gas stations you
know
um and what your dad was sending you
exactly literature Works literature
works for me too I was when I started uh
you know God just kind of gave me an
eye-opening Revelation in December 2011
I was just like whoa like we're in the
end and I just started picking up
anything I could find and uh yeah I
started finding stuff I was like well
I've never heard this before so big I
believe in the literature evangelism for
sure yeah and you know I think
the greatest literature evangelists that
ever lived is God himself
if he wasn't in the business of
literature evangelism none of us would
be here today we wouldn't have the Bible
and so that's that's my drive you know
and my passion and our passion as a
Ministry we train churches to get
involved in Sharing literature and we do
that all throughout North America and we
have a particular book that we share
it's called the Great controversy
powerful book have you guys heard of
that book okay so great controversy and
it comes with a Health Magazine but this
book has answers to Life's biggest
questions yeah you know it talks about
the deceptions of Satan it talks about
what happens when we die talks about the
Prophecies of the past present and the
future and above all gives hope to
people who are looking for a solid rock
in the midst of their great controversy
of their own lives and that's Jesus yeah
and so that's what we do travel
full-time do mission trips train
churches and work with churches at large
to uh just share hope in their Community
wow awesome it's amazing to see how far
you've come like cars can use anyone and
the fact that Jesus used your dad in
prison to reach out to you to then reach
out to his wife he was divorced from and
his son that is so powerful where's your
dad out today my dad is out of prison he
actually got out of prison the year that
I converted oh okay and uh him and my
mom are in a journey uh he lives about
five houses down still
and they're both on a journey and
following God and they have awesome
experienced a transformation of Christ
in their own lives and all the past you
know parents are here and they're like
you know I I did bad in the past now I'm
a new person know that God that your
influence through God's transformation
is the highest thing that can be done uh
for an example to your children any uh
any hope of reconciliation between the
two of them
in marriage no
no I don't know if your mom's
mom's anything my father's remarried
yeah but still strong friends you know
amazing yeah yeah wow yeah
yeah well praise the Lord for the work
he's done in you and thank you
sharing your story and I really hope
that people at home will be inspired
amen amen thank you yeah very powerful
thank you guys so much for watching if
you have a similar story or just want to
share testimony Drop it Down Below in
the comments make sure you hit like And
subscribe it always helps us out and you
can see anytime you upload new content
um if you want a t-shirt we've got
t-shirts you go to lightwear dot shop
we're not wearing them today I'm wearing
one yeah oh you are wearing one keithis
so if you like that t-shirt or any one
uh another one we've got so many
lightweight.shop if you want to donate
you can do so by going to patreon.com
Little Light Studios you'll get lots of
cool perks or you can go to
ls.tv slash give
um you can help us there out there as
well and other than that we'll see you
guys in the next episode
thank you
[Music]
if you're looking for good wholesome
educational content for your children
subscribe to our new channel little
light kids
foreign
[Music]
there has been very few movies in the
history of the world that have
completely changed our world and in 1999
a movie titled The Matrix hit the world
stage these stories are often told and
seen over and over again is it simply
just to make money
or is there something more nefarious
behind it
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you